[Música]
bienvenidos a europa hoy el programa de
actualidad europea de france 24 en
español sobre todo lo que acontece en la
unión europea y su papel en el mundo yo
soy esther herrera caro desde el
parlamento europeo en bruselas es un
placer saludarles es el programa de esta
semana en que analizaremos el nuevo
curso político que se inicia ahora
cuáles son los retos a los que se
enfrenta la unión europea después de un
año y medio de pandemia faltan cuatro
meses para que acabe el año el segundo
en pandemia ha habido éxitos como la
aplicación de un plan de recuperación de
750 mil millones de euros para recuperar
la economía lastrada por la crisis del
cobat y con una campaña de vacunación
coordinada la unión europea ha logrado
superar el objetivo de tener al menos el
70 por ciento de los adultos inmunizados
pero tiene otros desafíos algunos
inmediatos como la gestión de la
migración desde afganistán o las
importantes citas electorales en
alemania y francia- nos acompañan los
corresponsales en bruselas enrique
serbeto periodista del periodista del
periódico español abc y julia manresa
del periódico catalán ara para poder lo
analiza y todo pero antes un pequeño
repaso de lo que puede esperar a la
unión europea en este nuevo curso
la unión europea va de desafío en
desafío para mantener su liderazgo tras
la toma del control de los talibanes en
afganistán que ha provocado la
evacuación de miles de personas y una
oleada de migrantes el bloque europeo
aseguró que acogerá a las personas más
vulnerables una ayuda a medias tintas'
ya que por otra parte ha instado a los
refugiados a que se queden en países
como pakistán e irán para así evitar una
crisis de refugiados como la acontecida
en 2015 austria república checa y
dinamarca ya dijeron que no recibirán
afganos en cuanto al tema político este
año se espera varios cambios de gobierno
en alguno de los países del bloque
alemania celebrará elecciones las
primeras en 15 años sin angela merkel
también francia tiene pautados comicios
en la próxima primavera a la espera de
si la líder ultraderechista marine lepén
volverá a disputarse la presidencia como
ya ocurrió en 2017 por otra parte las
relaciones exteriores han sido un punto
focal en la agenda europea china siempre
en la mira por ser un rival sistémico
elevar la presencia de europa en
territorios como áfrica o américa
latina' los roces con rusia por su
participación en el conflicto con
ucrania debido a la disputa de la
península de crimea y con belarús por la
presión contra políticos de oposición
que han sido encarcelados y hasta
envenenados finalmente el grupo de
países europeos sorteó una serie de
tropiezos con la salida del break si la
pandemia y la campaña de vacunación a
las cuales tuvo que dar respuestas
contundentes para no perder su
credibilidad y su fortaleza interna como
grupo podrá con todo la unión europea
para poderla analizar todo tenemos a
enrique serbeto y a julian manresa julia
empezamos contigo llevamos un año y
medio de pandemia han ocurrido muchas
cosas desde marzo de 2020 la unión
europea ha sabido estar a la altura
creo que depende como todo en la unión
europea de la idea que tengamos de ella
y sobre todo de las expectativas que
tuviéramos de ella creo que se han hecho
cosas muy bien que ha estado a la altura
para para una gran mayoría es decir se
ha comprado conjuntamente vacunas para
que todos los países de la unión europea
tuvieron acceso a ellas se ha emitido
deuda deuda conjunta por primera vez
algo inédito impensable antes de la
pandemia pero ha habido otros fallos la
campaña de vacunación está siendo muy
desigual en los países que ya podíamos
prever que no iría también por lo tanto
creo que ahí se ha fallado al prever que
por ejemplo los países del este como
rumanía o bulgaria quedarían atrás en la
campaña de vacunación no sé no sé fue
transparente creo en la en toda la
negociación con las farmacéuticas y eso
tampoco
también era un poco previsible digamos y
creo que también ha habido fallos en la
negociación de este fondo de
recuperación se es
se dobló un poco la unión europea' ese
chantaje de hungría y polonia se les dio
mecanismos para que pudieran aprovechar
y evitar otra vez que se controle como
debería estar controlado el respeto a
los valores europeos y al estado de
derecho en la unión europea
la unión europea' enrique ha repetido
como un mantra que nadie estará seguro
hasta que todo el mundo del oeste es
decir que todo el mundo debe estar
vacunado para poder vencer a esta
pandemia pero hemos visto que apenas un
2% de los países con ingresos bajos o
medios solo han recibido una dosis
estamos creando un mundo de dos
velocidades
bueno el mundo ya tenía varias
velocidades antes de la pandemia es
evidente para la pandemia algo ha puesto
de manifiesto y es verdad yo estoy
completamente de acuerdo hasta que todo
el mundo no esté vacunado masivamente
vacunado el resto del mundo podemos
tener lo que queramos pero no estaremos
seguros qué es lo que puede hacer la
unión europea de momento es el principal
exportador de vacunas del mundo y el
principal o uno de los principales
donantes de vacunas al mecanismo kóvacs
de naciones unidades para que estos
países puedan tener también acceso a
estas vacunas el problema es que para
que eso sea eficaz necesitarían tener
también sistemas sanitarios modernos
flexibles eficientes y eso no lo tienen
en todos los países aquí no sé si aquí
puedo decir que ha faltado un poco esa
posición de unir fuerzas con eeuu puede
ser para la liberalización de patentes
en el caso de las vacunas para que todo
ese gran porcentaje de población mundial
que no está teniendo acceso a las
vacunas la tenga más fácilmente pero
sigue habiendo dificultades para
producirla es decir se necesitan también
laboratorios certificados y con
tecnologías suficientes y tampoco hay en
todo el mundo el debate de las de las
patentes las vacunas es obviamente
legítimo pero creo que tampoco es la
solución
y hablamos de crisis en crisis porque en
medio de este verano ha estallado la
crisis de afganistán
julia aunque es algo que se temía desde
hace tiempo la vuelta de los talibanes
al poder ahora la unión europea teme una
nueva crisis de refugiados como la
ocurrida en 2015 por ello insiste en que
la mayoría de personas que pidan asilo
se queden en esa región a cambio la
unión europea se compromete a donar
dinero a los países vecinos como irán o
también pakistán ha ganado el populismo
en europa
no sé si diría que ha ganado el
populismo pero lo que sí está claro es
que el discurso que debe apuntalar la
unión europea de defender los valores
europeos los derechos fundamentales el
discurso de la acogida se ha dejado
vencer por el discurso de la xenofobia
del miedo creo que la unión europea ha
llegado a esta nueva crisis con los
deberes por hacer que nunca se cerró la
que se abría en 2015 que nunca se supo
gestionar
otra vez esa posición de ciertos países
que no están dispuestos a asumir la
responsabilidad y la solidaridad que
implica estar en una unión europea-27 y
este será el gran reto yo creo de este
año incluso de los años que vendrán que
al final al fin y al cabo es un es un
reto que llevamos arrastrando desde hace
años y que parece muy difícil si países
que deberían abanderar como ahora mismo
por ejemplo españa que tiene un gobierno
de izquierdas deberían estar abanderando
este discurso de la acogida no no lo
hacen no son valientes y no son capaces
de asumir el coste político que también
implica este este discurso hasta qué
punto debemos preocuparnos de una futura
crisis migratoria teniendo en cuenta que
las fronteras están cerradas que
pakistán ya ha dicho que los refugiados
no se pueden no son acogidos en pakistán
hasta qué punto debemos preocuparnos
pues yo en estos momentos tengo una
opinión
digamos dividida o sea por un lado
efectivamente no deberíamos preocuparnos
aunque vinieran los 14 millones de
afganos en la población europea serían
una proporción insignificante son no no
ese es el problema el problema son las
consecuencias políticas de las que
hablabas juliá que una llegada brusca de
extranjeros y de extranjeros que vienen
cargados digamos con una imagen que todo
el mundo puede entender
provoca reacciones políticas que
resultan indeseables en la mayor parte
de los países en ese sentido y ahí es
donde estamos arrastrando todavía el
temor de lo que pasó en 2015 ahora en
estos momentos tal como estoy viendo yo
conozco bien afganistán en el fondo y yo
creo que los que se han quedado en
afganistán las mujeres que están
saliendo a la calle a decir a los
talibanes que no las pueden vencer yo
creo que son más necesarias allí que
aquí no no yo no puedo hablar en su
nombre porque eso es un sacrificio que
yo no soy nadie para pedírselo pero sí
es cierto que ahora mismo me pregunto si
no son más necesarias es toda esa gente
que les estamos diciendo venir a europa
porque os vamos a no sé si son más
necesarios allí para construir digamos
las bases de un futuro con la realidad
que hay que es que los talibanes han
tomado el poder
y me siento especialmente orgulloso y
aplaudo esas imágenes que están llegando
desde ayer de anteayer de mujeres que
salen a la calle que se enfrentan a los
talibanes para decirles
participar en la vida pública y queremos
ser personas la no queremos que nos
someta es la salida de afganistán tan
atropellada por parte de eeuu ha sido la
gota que ha colmado el vaso para europa
bueno ha sido realmente un fracaso
espectacular fracaso colectivo en
general
específico para eeuu y del que hay que
leer muy bien las lecciones para el
futuro porque a partir de ahora yo creo
que occidente generará perdido mucha de
su credibilidad cuando uno nos dice que
va a una operación para ayudar a
reconstruir un país uno no sabe cuándo
entonces se producirá de repente una
desbandada como esta pero en términos
técnicos yo creo que la alianza con eeuu
sigue siendo necesaria en españa en
europa hay
en francia en cualquier país hay hay 50
mil tropas capacitadas para llevar a
cabo esa misión lo que no tenemos es la
tecnología las infraestructuras los
satélites todas estas cosas que los
americanos si tienen y que europa sigue
necesitando para esa proyección militar
en el exterior o sea no es una
casualidad ni es una cuestión de
imprevisión o de que hubiera más tropas
americanas aunque hubiéramos mandado
50.000 tropas europeas a kabul al
aeropuerto de kabul sin la
infraestructura tecnológica de los
americanos no hubiéramos podido hacer
nada justamente uno de las cuestiones
donde puede haber cooperación es con la
de rusia entre la unión europea y eeuu
los últimos años han sido muy complejos
con las relaciones con rusia y la unión
europea hay algún resquicio para mejorar
estas relaciones
me cuesta verlo
recuerdo que una de las últimas cumbres
antes de vacaciones de verano a merkel y
macro me pusieron sobre la mesa la
posibilidad de reunirse otra vez y
después de muchos años con rusia y eso
generó mucho recelo en los países que
temen más a la influencia o la
injerencia más bien rusa y hubo una
cumbre con biden y putin que tampoco fue
muy bien y me cuesta ver no veo ideas de
cómo mejorar o cómo innovar en la
relación que la unión europea mantiene
con rusia así se reunió se renuevan los
pilares que ya existían
se habla de ser contundentes exigentes
pero a la vez de ese engagement no
político que tiene que es inevitable
pero pero creo que falta falta
contundencia y sobre todo faltan nuevas
ideas un nuevo enfoque yo creo que no es
así rusia es un país muy grande
y está al lado de europa y tiene sus
propios intereses y no conseguiremos
llevarnos bien con rusia ni que la
reacción sea útil hasta que sus
intereses
coincidan con los nuestros y la
principal diferencia es que europa es un
conjunto de democracias y rusia no lo es
y hasta que rusia no sea una democracia
no habrá ninguna manera de cooperar pero
creo que los errores que hemos cometido
en la gestión de ciertos asuntos como el
de ucrania
han hecho que sea cada vez más difícil y
han reforzado mucho a putin como un
autócrata que es lo que es pues enrique
juliá esto ha sido todo muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros en europa
hoy esto ha sido todo nosotros les
esperamos en una próxima emisión de
france 24 en español de europa hoy
[Música]